well the statement was released by bam
Palace just after 6 p.m. local time here
in London uh revealing the news that the
King has been diagnosed with a form of
cancer in this statement it says that
during the king's recent Hospital
procedure for benign prostate
enlargement a separate issue of concern
was noted subsequent diagnostic tests
have identified a form of cancer the
statement goes on to to say that today
the king commenced a schedule of regular
treatments but he has been advised by
doctors to postpone public facing duties
his majesty it says will continue to
undertake State business and official
paperwork as usual the king thanked his
medical team in the statement it went on
to say that he remains wholly positive
about his treatment and looks forward to
returning to full public duty as soon as
possible
it said his majesty has chosen to share
his diagnosis to prevent speculation and
in the hope that it may assist public
understanding for all those around the
world who are affected by cancer so we
do not know the form of cancer that the
King has been diagnosed with nor do we
know how long it will take to treat he
is broadly healthy for a 75-year-old but
despite his optimism there is of course
great concern at this sudden news
Redmond Channon Global News London